thousands of visitors flocked in the
14th edition of the tuning world
bodensee trade fair on Lake Constance to
catch up on the latest trends this year
the tuning scene seems to be divided
into two camps on the one hand there's
the car customizers looking to buff up
older models and on the other are the
new car buyers looking to add some
pizzazz to their vehicles but whatever
the reason Germany's automotive
accessories industry is reaping the
benefits with global sales of 4.6
billion euros last year
10 Samuel tuning experts when Schultz
says this year's trend is too old cards
classics and modern classics like
original Beatles older opal cadets
first-generation VW golf's and old
beamers buyers give them modern wheels
and lower bodies taking care not to ruin
the classic lines the car should still
look like it did in the 1970s or 80s
thence when says there's the opposing
trend people buy brand new cars with
powerful engines of BMW m3 or a Golf R
and fit them with a really big Porsche
braking system pricey rims and
performance air or racing suspensions
with its whopping output of 1,500
horsepower this tune 2015 toyota supra
is one of the most powerful cars at the
fair the owner mateos me ja a car tuner
from poland has done everything to make
his vehicle lighter and faster he has
spent more than 100,000 euros souping up
his supra
well the carriage meant for drifting so
this is where we need this power you
have with that much horsepower it can be
a tricky but still it's a lot of fun
mass market or luxury brand that is the
question here for many the answer is
evident one of the best-selling and
seemingly most two models of all is the
Golf GTI VW celebrated the gulls 40th
anniversary with an area of its own into
fair
like it's already loaded in this win
says some find that to standard and want
something special if they have the cash
folks take a portion Lamborghini or
Nissan GTR and rebuild it they optimize
a new car straight from the factory with
even better brakes or tweaked its body
that's a fine line to tread some managed
to make the car even nicer though there
are some fo parts to the aware but
generally the camps are divided between
volume brands and high-performance
vehicles which are quite popular these
days when it comes to the likes of
Porsches Lamborghinis for the mercedes
AMG c63s you might think there's nothing
that could be improved upon this tutor
says to be honest they're almost perfect
when they leave the factory a new
Porsche is already a real pleasure to
drive but people want to individualize
their cars and show their own taste if
i'm outside the result is something like
this a porsche cayman gt4 and boasts 448
horsepower performance tires and tuned
wheels it's available for a starting
price of 150 thousand euros
this lamborghini aventador super veloce
costs around 350,000 euros it has an
output of 750 horsepower and has been
upgraded with a triple adjustable
coilover suspension
France diamond lives and Dubai and
specializes in tuning luxury cars pilot
elem he says there are lots of
Lamborghinis Porsches and Ferraris
around so to look different from the 20
other Ferrari 458 you've got to do
something that's why they do this
concave wheels have become an absolute
must these premium rims way just a kilo
and cost 370 euros a piece tuning world
also host shows to entertain visitors
dance industry warmed up the crowds with
their LED backlight routines but this
ford mustang GT 5.0 was truly hot at
temperatures of around 30 degrees
celsius its thermal paint transforms the
unassuming car into a real hot ride
love you
alongside all the latest trends the fair
also shows that some things never go out
of style drift shows for instance the
drivers thrilled spectators with their
pirouettes for many tuning world just
wouldn't be complete without the smell
of burning rubber
you